why in the world are pilots paid so much  at Delta even new first officers earn 92  dollars per hour this number goes all  the way up to 354 dollars per hour for  the most experienced captains a very  similar pay scale can be found at  American and United as well the reason  isn't rocket science like any job  they're paid in accordance to their  demand demand for Aviation has been  skyrocketing for decades but the supply  of Pilots hasn't quite kept up the main  reason for this is all of the insane  requirements to become a pilot you  literally need over a thousand hours  worth of experience before you can even  get your first Airline job this issue  has only been accelerated by the tech  industry which has been able to offer  higher salaries with less education time  so the majority have chosen the tech  industry over the aviation industry and  it's really only the passionate ones  that end up as Pilots